il est 7h55 mardi 27 juin sur le
boulevard Jacques Germain Soufflot à
Nanterre Mercedes Classe A jaune canari
immatriculé avec une plaque polonaise
surgit sur la chaussée et roule à vive
allure sur la voie réservée au bus c'est
dans cette voiture que se trouve Naël
ainsi que deux autres jeunes domotard de
la compagnie territoriale de circulation
et de sécurité routière des
Hauts-de-Seine prennent aussitôt le
véhicule en chasse afin de contrôler
celui-ci au regard de sa conduite mais
aussi du jeune âge apparent des
occupants du véhicule les deux
fonctionnaires ont tenté une première
fois de procéder à un contrôle en
activant leurs avertisseurs sonores et
lumineux se portant à la hauteur du
véhicule au niveau d'un feu rouge et en
lui indiquant vous stationner le
véhicule alors redémarré en grillant le
feu rouge les deux motards continuent la
course poursuite sur plusieurs axes de
Nanterre elle traverse le rond-point des
droits de l'homme on la voit aussi rue
Pablo Neruda rue des Trois fontanots et
enfin sur le boulevard de Pesaro où ils
activent de nouveau leur gyrophare en
vain à 8h16 les deux policiers ont avisé
par radio leur collègue de la situation
selon le procureur de la République de
Nanterre au cours de ce périple
plusieurs éléments dont les déclarations
des policiers et les images de
vidéosurveillance permettent de
constater plusieurs infractions au code
de la route notamment des traversées de
passage piétons mettant en danger un
piéton et un cycliste la Mercedes est
finalement contrainte de s'arrêter au
niveau du boulevard de la défense stoppé
par des embouteillages les deux motards
mettent alors pied-à-terre
mettant pied-à-terre sur le côté et
derrière le véhicule Mercedes les
policiers affirment avoir crié au
conducteur de s'arrêter en se
positionnant sur le côté gauche du
véhicule l'un au niveau de la portière
du conducteur l'autre près de l'aile
avant gauche il précise dans le cadre de
leurs auditions avoir tous deux sorties
leurs armes et les avoir pointé sur le
conducteur pour le dissuader de
redémarrer en lui demandant de couper le
contact au moment où le véhicule a
redémarré
le policier situé près de l'aile du
véhicule attiré une fois sur le
conducteur la voiture poursuit alors sa
route sur quelques mètres plus loin au
niveau du passage Arago avant de venir
s'encastrer place Nelson Mandela à 8h19
à 8h21 l'auteur du tir qui produit les
premiers secours et suppléés par les
pompiers qui arrivent sur place il tente
de le réanimer mais il est déjà trop
tard Naël 17 ans touché au bras et aux
thorax décède des suites de ses
blessures à 9h15 sous le choc le
passager arrière s'extrait du véhicule
pour être aussitôt interpellé le second
passager à quant à lui pris la fuite
placé en garde à vue à l'IGPN le
policier auteur du tir à justifier son
tir par la volonté d'éviter une nouvelle
fuite du véhicule la dangerosité du
comportement routier du conducteur
induisant chez le policier la peur que
quelqu'un soit renversé ou la crainte
d'être percutée par le véhicule explique
le procureur de la République de
Nanterre toutefois ce dernier a estimé
que les conditions légales de l'usage de
l'arme n'étaient pas réunies le policier
a été mis en examen dans le cadre de
l'enquête pour homicide volontaire par
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique ouverte mardi une autre enquête
a aussi été ouverte simultanément pour
refus d'obtempérer et tentative
d'homicide volontaire sur personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique